hello my name is hardened balotra and I
am with mahindra satyam and I'm really
enjoying this world economic forum that
is going on here in Brazil in Rio and
the question I am selected to answer
from the youth of Latin America is what
you see as a distinguishing strength in
Latin America and how will the strength
grow and impact development so I you
know I've been coming to Latin America
for the last two years now and I think
what I find is just a white flint
environment here and what I mean by that
is the social and cultural environment
that's there in Latin America is
unbelievably amazing I think would be
mixture we have our races cultures and
language I think this creates an
opportunity that is not found anywhere
in the world today even though America
or not vertical us save and I'm from
calls itself a melting pot I think Latin
America is truly a melting what I think
whenever I visit here the amount of
diversity I see here is unbelievable and
I strongly believe that that kind of
diversity and the openness of the people
have here we create the next decade will
be very important for Latin America line
in Latin America this errant decade is
the indicative Latin American and if the
government policies are favorable which
I hope they will be an ISIL or trade in
my direction I think we'll see
tremendous growth in this region it is
endowed with natural resources I think
technologically there are a lot of
advancements going on there is a lot of
discovery going on in fields like oil
and others so with all these combined we
see tremendous potential in Latin
America and that's why we are the
company here my first attempt is also
very invested here not only on RIT side
but also our other businesses so I'll
sign off by saying wishing you all a
good luck here in Latin America and we
want to contribute it will be part of
your journey and hopefully Latin America
will be the continent for this decade
thank you